let's instead go to ryan from
massachusetts ryan from massachusetts
you were on
oh my god no way you actually picked me
um
i'm a huge fan of the videos and i just
had a question on
the hunter biden scandal so i wanted
your thoughts on that if you thought it
was just a big
whole sham um if because i watched some
of the interview
with uh tucker carlson and uh
one of uh biden's uh uh hunter biden's
associates
tony i forget his name
yeah that's what it was so i just wanted
your thoughts on that
if you thought it was um like a big
scam just like how in 2016 with hillary
and russia
and all that i wanted uh i was wondering
if you thought it was like the same
thing
so listen the i i am sure
that by mere chance there are
some assertions that have been made by
rudy
the new york post babalinsk you know
whatever i'm sure that there are some
aspects
and they could be relatively innocuous
that are true
about some of this but
understand that the story starts with
the idea
that we learned about this because
hunter biden
flew across the country to have three
laptops repaired by a legally blind guy
who despite admitting he didn't actually
see
hunter biden because he's legally blind
a bo biden foundation sticker on the
laptop
makes him sure it was hunter biden and
the guy
when hunter biden never picked up the
laptops he flew across the country to
have repaired
uh accessed the private emails
and then gave them to the fb i mean you
know it's it's outrageous
and so i i you know if you say
did hunter biden was he really working
with burisma it's like okay yeah that's
true
but it the story they are telling is
such obvious desperation
everybody who's tried to corroborate it
can't do it
it's wacky i know i was just wondering
if you thought like people would
actually like believe that and that
could have an effect on the election
so there's two questions there do people
believe it yes
there are people on the trump side who
are convinced about it
is it going to affect the election i
really don't think so i really don't
this is an
election that is so qualitative in
what's going on it's about the pandemic
it's about the economy
i don't think this is at all like the
hillary's email story
which really did get some uh some hold
definitely yeah um yeah thank you for
answering that um
i just ah man i forget my other question
now well your first one was so good you
i would go out on top if i were you
okay yeah rather than risking an
inferior question
yeah um all right
i'm gonna help you my friend i really
appreciate the call and i hope to hear
from you again
all right thank you thank you so much
yeah he was gonna go and then end up
going out lower and we don't want that
so uh
i think we're gonna keep it going this
way one of our sponsors today is
vincero watches and they're giving you
15
off everything in the store if you're a
guy looking for the perfect way
to refresh your style one of the best
investments you can make is in a high
quality wrist watch vincero is an
american company
that has made it possible for everyday
people to afford
a premium watch almost everything they
sell is within the range of about two
hundred dollars but it'll look
like you spent a lot more all of their
watches are made in small batches from
top
quality materials and they just look
great i went on their site and picked
out
a watch from their icon automatic
collection the one i got is in mesh
matte black and i love it it's simple
sleek elegant
goes great with just about anything i'm
wearing and i've gotten a ton of
compliments on it
you'll get 15 percent off everything in
their store when you go to
davidpakman.com
vincero i've put the link right
underneath this video